if you want to fight against the country  you need an F-15 you need something a  little more than a gun and who are they  shooting at shooting at these guys  behind me  so first of all on his  claims of fact they're just not true if  you wanted to fight the American  government you would need an F-15  um that's interesting uh what what does  Afghanistan have to say about that  because last time I checked the goat  herders in Afghanistan were able to fend  off the Americans in a 20-year war with  little more than black powder rifles  Afghanistan is the size of Texas in this  kind of Doomsday scenario where the  government turns to radical and starts  attacking the American people you don't  think that some members of the U.S  military are going to defect at that  point most military service members I  know are pretty patriotic people I don't  think they'd fire on their own citizens